un intrus est introduit dans le centre
du réseau des caméras de sécurité de
repos et sur place
il a tué un de leurs employés
[Musique]
du Pacifique
aujourd'hui ils vont se relier au réseau
de rôle et démarrer le programme
maintenant je veux que tu me dises la
vérité qu'est-ce qu'un garçon de
tournage fait sur ce bateau et
maintenant ça risque de tomber entre de
mauvaises mains j'ai été impatient de te
voir chérie
[Musique]
je vais envoyer la bouée du Pacifique
dans l'obscurité des abysses
[Musique]
j'ai changé
fais-moi confiance viens
je te jure je vais te sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on doit se dire au revoir
Conan